en un año en donde todo cambio para las
salas de cine a causa del aislamiento
las plataformas digitales se fortalecen
de nuevo netflix vuelve a liderar las
nominaciones en los globos de oro son 20
aspiraciones en televisión 6 de ellas
para the crown
en lo que se refiere al cine la
plataforma digital cuenta con 22
nominaciones cifras muy superiores a las
de cualquier otro estudio disney plus
hace su debut en los globos de oro con
su popular demanda lorian un spin-off de
star wars
mismo caso para ellos biomax en su caso
con the fire atiendan la película en
blanco y negro manga de netflix es el
largometraje con más nominaciones
dirigida por david fincher
esta cinta dramatiza la producción del
clásico ciudadano kane cuenta con un
total de 6 en una categoría en donde
compite con norma hablan de disney esta
última muy premiada en lo que va de la
temporada
usted es guatemala consiguió por primera
vez una nominación para los globos de
oro de la mano de la llorona de jairo
bustamante es una obra que combina el
terror con una metáfora de un conflicto
armado de la nominación es el premio es
el hecho de estar con cinco películas
maravillosas representando diferentes
culturas representando diferentes
esquinas del mundo
y luego de esto nos toma con mucho
con mucho honor porque para para
guatemala y para la región de
centroamérica esto es un hecho histórico
3 mujeres hicieron historia en la
categoría de mejor dirección de una
película dramática una cuantía nunca
antes vista
la cita es el próximo 28 de febrero en
una ceremonia virtual emitida desde
nueva york y beverly hills